hey what's up you guys Denny with et
online I'm at the Auto Club Speedway in
Fontana I got this suit on because I'm
about to find out what it's like to be
in one of those guys as part of the
IndyCar experience but before that I'm
get a couple tips from indy car driver
and former dancing with the stars pro
Elio Castro nobis so before we talk race
you know I got to talk to you about
Dancing with the Stars yep you're a
former champ your partner julianne hough
is gonna be a fourth judge this season
what do you think of how you think she's
gonna fair with Lynn and although she's
gonna be awesome first of all she's a
she's a chance and not only that she
knows exactly she's a professional
exactly where to look i remember the
explanation that she's telling me you
know and sometimes you you don't
understand so she'll be very good to a
be simple explaining to the fans and
what we understood I believe she's gonna
be to tackling would you have a return
as a judge on the panel if they invited
you well maybe is a judge a fancy I'm
done why I hang up my shoes now I'm just
racing shoes I think I got the trophy on
exact god you're up for the series
championship basis we can hear Fontana
that's right how's the training how's
the prep going where everything's going
well we are battling with my teammate
which is uh it's it's interesting
because Team Penske you know you know we
have a very good status hearing in in
fontana which is great the venules is
diseased your teammates who exactly what
you're going to have he's going to have
to sew but in the end of the day it's a
great problem for the team to have
because no matter what it sounds like
they're going to be the champion they're
going for the direction and we've been
waiting for a long time and up I'm proud
to uh to be part of it and but hopefully
I'll be the one to give to it it's a fun
track to as I'm gonna find out soon yes
you're gonna have a great time the
biggest advice I would give you don't
forget to breathe haha are you guys
before I get into this bad boy here's
the person driving me Sarah Fisher how's
it going it's going good my life is in
your hands today you're right I'm a
little nervous should I be nervous not
at all man I
been driving since 2000 so I have a lot
of a lot of history behind so you just
had a baby two months ago how'd it feel
to be a badass well you know it's it's
it's like riding a bike I actually
haven't been in the car since what 2010
so maybe you should be a little worried
no it's like it's like a bicycle right
if you're bicyclists or you know you're
a runner you get back on the treadmill
and it's like feeling at home so that'll
be very much what it is today now how
fast does this guy go oh go today you
know we'll probably go around 170 around
there they'll run here about 220 miles
an hour so you know we're not quite
there at the real race pace but we'll
get it we'll get you fast enough that
you feel like you're flying I'm excited
but I'm not gonna lie a little bit
should we do it yep let's go
real life oh oh I shouldn't have that
burrito for lunch